TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THANKS A LOT FOR
THAT, MATT.
YOU MAY BE ONE OF THEM, TENS OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ARE NOW
UNEMPLOYED AND RUNNING OUT OF
MONEY.
THE REST HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
LOSING THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS AND MANY OF THEM ARE
GONE.
ONE GROUP OF AMERICANS HAS NO
WORRY AT ALL ABOUT GETTING
WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THE HOMELESS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO ANYWAY,
OFFICIALS ARE PUTTING UP THE
HOMELESS FOR FREE AND CITY
HOTELS AND SUPPLYING THEM WITH
FREE ALCOHOL, DRUGS, AND
NICOTINE.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS?
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I CAN’T THINK OF A CLEARER
SIGNAL TO TAXPAYERS, CITIZENS,
PEOPLE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THINGS THAT WE JUST HATE YOU AND
ARE SPENDING ALL OF OUR TIME ON
PEOPLE WHO AREN’T CONTRIBUTING.
I MEAN HONESTLY.
WHY WOULD THEY BE GIVING THE
HOMELESS FREE STUFF?
>> IT’S NOT JUST THAT, THE WORST
PART IS THAT WE ARE TAKING A
VERY VULNERABLE POPULATION AND
FEEDING THEIR ADDICTION.
AND WE ARE NOT USING TAX DOLLARS
TO DO THAT, WHICH BEGS THE
QUESTION WHERE IS THIS MONEY
COMING FROM?
IF THE REASON WE ARE NOT USING
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IS BECAUSE IT
WOULD OTHERWISE NOT BE LEGAL TO
DO?
THE IDEA THAT THE GOVERNMENT FOR
THE GOOD OF THE MANY, IT’S
IMMORAL.
DEBATED OVER YEARS, IT’S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
VERY UN-AMERICAN FOR THAT
MATTER, BY FEDERAL STANDARDS
ILLEGAL WHICH PROBABLY EXPLAINS
WHY SOME OF THE HOTELS AS YOU
READ IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA ARE
REFUSING TO PARTICIPATE.
>> Tucker: SO THE LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL, I KNOW YOU ARE
FROM NORTHERN SAN FRANCISCO, HAS
THREATENED TO COMMANDEER HOTELS
THAT DON’T WANT TO BECOME
HOMELESS SHELTERS.
JUST AT THE LEVEL OF CONCERN --
RIGHT, I AM FOR HELPING THE
HOMELESS.
SO MANY NEED ACTUAL HELP, THEY
DON’T NEED TO LIVE ON THE
SIDEWALK.
BUT ALL THE CONCERN SEEMS TO BE
FOR THE HOMELESS, BUT ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING REALLY
HARD TO DO WELL FOR THEIR KIDS
AND MAKE SOCIETY BETTER?
THEY ARE TOTALLY IGNORED.
WHY QUESTION MIKE >> THAT’S
RIGHT, ESPECIALLY WITH THE FOOD
SHORTAGE, WE SHOULD BE
FEEDING THEIR STOMACHS, NOT
THEIR ADDICTIONS.
I GUESS THEY FEEL AS THOUGH WE
CAN FEND FOR OURSELVES, I THINK
THE REAL CONCERN HERE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH IS TO GIVE
THEM A LITTLE BIT OF CREDIT,
THEY DON’T WANT TO SPREAD THE
COVID DISEASE.
SOME OF THESE HOMELESS PEOPLE
THAT ARE GETTING METHADONE,
MARIJUANA, ALCOHOL, SOME OF THEM
ARE NOT EVEN COVID POSITIVE BUT
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
FORCE THEM INTO SELF-ISOLATION
BY FEEDING THESE ADDICTIONS.
THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG ABOUT
THAT, THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
NOT LEGALLY DETAINED.
THE CITY IS SAYING NO, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE YOU DON’T POISON
OTHER PEOPLE AND WE WILL FEED
YOUR ADDICTIONS TO MAKE SURE YOU
STAY THERE.
THERE’S SOMETHING VERY CRUEL
ABOUT THAT, AND THE FACT THAT WE
ARE NOT TAKING CARE OF THE REST
OF THIS CITY AND FEEDING SOME OF
THE HUNGRY PEOPLE AND NOT
FOCUSING ON THE HUNGER ISSUES IS
VERY TROUBLING.
>> Tucker: I LOVE
SAN FRANCISCO, AND I WANTED TO
THRIVE BUT I’M WORRIED THE ONLY
PEOPLE LEFT WILL BE THE